kids are dumb we all know this that's
okay
kids describe color to a blind person
now that's just
impossible why did they do this
how would you do this what would you say
what would you possibly say
oh it's like uh
[Laughter]
oh god i can't wait to see this
because it's super big
what my name is mac and i am totally
blind
never seen anything ever that is
fascinating though
how would you how i mean
i am totally blind i am as blind as a
bat oh actually blinds aren't bad at all
they just see which zoner okay you
see colors well you probably know that i
i i don't see i i like how they they
brought all this fruit in so they can go
hey look at this
oh wait you can't like why would they do
that interrupt the video for very
exciting announcement we're bringing
back
the pewdiepie rhino shield collaboration
i got
the best phone cases on the market show
footage of of their strengths
oh no now imagine that without your
phone you need
pewdiepie rhino shield phone case to 19
lucky 19 year olds we're giving away 19
tamperings custom pewdiepie
show them sad oh now i want to smack
that
any order that orders at least one case
within the next seven days
qualifies to enter the greatest giveaway
of all time
rhino shield also launched four new
colors that you can pair with pewdiepie
designs
poppy orange berry red dark teal and
sand beige looking very sexy
what i really love about rhino shield
cases is how much you can customize them
and make them exactly how you want it
you can add your name to it change the
buttons
change the frame change the colors make
it just how you want it
we have of course the wave design again
with the pixelated and also
the non-pixelated version highly
requested if you missed out last time
now's your chance baby it's available in
20 different colors god
add any name with the 10 letters or any
epic meme
10 letters we also have the floor again
2069 batch design
it comes when when you made it with a
custom engraving pick out one for
yourself
pick out one for another one for
yourself pick out
all for yourself you deserve but wait
more on top of more free shipping
worldwide that's a double ah
but wait there's more on top of more
more lifetime warranty on these bad boys
huh
[Music]
it still hurts even though i know it's
fine it's available for all android or
i guess if you're apple flagship devices
but the best part about this whole promo
is that if you enter the code pewdiepie
you get 20 off 20
off time to stock up on lifetime
warranty cases
this is only within the first 48 hours
so you take your chance now
don't stall this enter the code
pewdiepie check out and get 20
on they have a ton of other cool designs
like nba league of legends
nasa check them out customize try it out
on the website see what you like and uh
yeah it also comes with bigger pp that's
right five percent
at least all right link is in the
description pewdiepie you know what to
do let's get on with the video
course you see well yes i do actually
trying really hot yeah it's impossible
colors i never even seen before very
true
have you ever saw a color
of it oh oh i got it i got it
you give them skittles and you say this
is green
and then try that try the red one that's
right
i can't think of a better way i
literally can a blueberry
i've never seen anything ever that's the
whole point
i gotta see that again have you
ever saw a color of a blueberry
i've never seen anything ever that's the
whole point
the patience of this dude i love it
well he can't see my shirt but i mean
like
his butt no he can't i can't see that
but what sound
do you think
what was he going to say i want to know
um and speaking of blue your pants are
blue
well jeans so what about me
oh god this is so mean
i can't think of anything more
frustrating than enduring this being
blind and having children trying to
explain and
no thank you being blind is tough enough
red
red is like fire and like madness
i think red could like an explosion
what would you like reminds me of blood
blood blood blood oh yeah like
oh that's i'm fat i'm sorry okay
why what are they doing wrap this up
it's painful or it's like a warm color
or a warm orange
orange orange or fruits my favorite
color is dark orange dark orange
you mean brown you fool
because it's so dark why it's called
find the orange
okay i can find it easy oh
boogers if somebody like has green
boogers
get out of here stop these children okay
she's a little older
maybe she says something good somebody
like farted
green is far green huh yeah green is
water don't don't feed this man lies huh
green makes me feel like a zombie ooh a
zombie huh
there's none um white of course because
you can't see white
and no black white like we can see white
did he say he can't see white you can
see why
in a rainbow okay that makes sense
why is brown mean color is it because it
reminds you of poop
and then yellow i like how we kept that
joke for two different audiences
that's great would be like the
kid who could who's a good kid but can
never sit still like
oh hey how are you doing like yellow
light sounds like one she's using sound
effects to describe
sounds and i i that's at least better
than what anyone else has done
what would you associate like taylor
swift color
i know bright peppy girlish pink what
are you on about what are you doing
stop here there's a sound
it's floating in my mouth oh my god
unicorns exploding in your mouth i
learned something new every day
wow that was incredible
what a video we gotta watch more kids
doing stuff
kids meet a woman with tourette have you
ever been bullied
i was bullied a lot when i was in school
they would
not want to play with me they would call
me the r word
i'll be your friend you will be my
friend
okay kids guess a pass now they're nice
hi micah
hi i love your outfit you are dressed
really snazzy today
thank you i'm just waiting for her to
cuss up a storm but that's clearly not
the kind of turret she has
dang it is that insensitive probably i'm
sorry okay
sorry you wanted it to what is that
tourette syndrome is a neurological
disorder
that causes people to have tics and body
movements that they can't control
like see what i just did right there
that's part of it
is he interested or freaked out what is
his face
i remember when someone told me about
teres i'm like that's not real
you have a thing that makes you swear no
that's made up that
that doesn't even make sense how come
they swear though
because i i can make sense out of it in
my own head but i don't know if it's
true like
the way i would see it is that you try
to prevent the tick
but that just makes it worse in your
brain and that's what makes you swear
out at least that i can relate to
why do turret it's caused by damage to
the
amygdala a region of the brain that
normally mitigates anger and aggression
because cursing is form of verbal
aggression
having a dollar damage could result in
the inability to control
aggression including verbal aggression
or cussing
but this doesn't make sense to me
because
they're not aggressive in their nature
people with tourette
are just like anyone else this is a
hypothesis
though so i guess people don't know for
sure
i'll go with my apost
you see what i'm doing right now yeah
yeah does it make you nervous
oh it's like when your brain is an
right
if you tell your brain okay i don't want
to do that don't think of that
brain is like oh really oh i oh okay
let me fix that for you i think what you
wanted is the complete opposite and
you're just like oh god oh why
that's tourette's brain super
i think i got it i don't need a
scientist to tell me so i can't do
anything about it it just
happens all the time all day long
usually when that happens to me i take
deep breaths
you do let me try
[Music]
nope they're still there is stuttering
and tourette related because
a closer friend of mine when i was young
had uh stuttering
okay i'm not the only one asking the
question wow
okay interesting it's like a combination
there's like lots and lots of different
tics
i have like you're doing yeah like i'm
doing it right now
but i don't blurt out any words yeah
did you see somebody with that kind um
yeah yeah and it's really rare that
people do that
really that that would be pretty sad if
you couldn't control it
you just yelled something out people
could hear what you're talking about
or what you're thinking because it just
comes out it doesn't mean they're
thinking it that doesn't mean they want
to think it okay
don't say that hey don't feed this kid's
lines all right
brain the king can help it's
society that makes them not want to say
it and that makes them say it
nothing to do with me and when you like
walk a
crop it's not that terrible it could
happen to anyone at any point
okay i'm done with this video kids meet
bobby's i'm funny
oh my gosh
why does bonnabelle love to do that so
well i guess it gets a laugh out of kids
but
it's so weird pleasure to meet you we
have big hands you wanna
right do you do wrestling i
do not yeah no wrestling
do you he wanted to say yes so bad dude
body holder is the one that builds their
body
that's right i train my muscles so that
they are
symmetrical and proportionate and they
look balanced and beautiful
well yeah yeah
[Music]
all right pop is never heard of a pack
pop pack pop nope how about now look at
my chest switches
what is that
[Laughter]
it's like that's not that's unlawful
ungodly can't look at that
man is like hell yeah
20 years damn why that sounds like a
testimony to
that dedication that's impressive people
forget that
just how much time and work goes into
building your body
i started then you can do steroids i
mean working out and training with
weights when i was like 16 years old
sometimes when my dad is exercising up
in his room
i come and exercise with him nice
awesome you're already on your way to
holding muscle let's see it
oh yeah that's my favorite exercise
like this when you do a setup you sit up
oh yeah i can't do those they're hard
huh
i would love to see your children
are you ready let's see what you can do
perfect crunch how much
do you work out the truth is i only
train for about an hour two times a day
sometimes
two times a day god damn but still yeah
you don't have to
spend 24 hours in the gym spend all my
time in the kitchen eating
i always get hungry once i eat food i
ask for more and
never stop and girl
[Music]
you make a great bodybuilder what do you
eat
i eat at least six meals a day
yeah yeah i have to eat an ungodly
amount
sushi i also like you like sushi
yeah awesome is sushi good football
good for bulking sushi yeah yeah what's
your biggest
weight that you've lifted i picked 700
pounds up off the ground
[Music]
damn
how much do you weigh i weigh 320 pounds
does he um yeah anyway
it would take eight of you to make one
of me
he can make like take each child on each
limb and then you have him
that's nuts what size clothes do you
wear a triple
extra extra extra large does your mom
make your clothes
she yeah she she has she's made me a few
yeah
have you ever been too big to get in
something
[Music]
rollercoasters yeah there you go i was
so upset
i couldn't ride it i was too big can
anyone come
become a bodybuilder absolutely because
i want to
be strong when i grow up oh i think it's
a great idea
i think it's a great idea you should
read up on homer the alien your honesty
study the greek idea
did you know in ancient greek the slaves
were banned from the gyms
my wife is a bodybuilder really yeah
she's right there
yeah yeah girls can definitely be
bodybuilders oh yeah show me your body
sure would you like to try one with me
no you should no come on do it
do it yeah
good job
this is a great video i enjoy it nice to
meet you nice to meet you too buddy
you take care all right cool well i was
kids learning about stuff
i feel like i learned about stuff maybe
you did as well if you enjoyed
leave a like subscribe for more videos
and i'll see you guys in the next one
brofist you thought it was gay
but true relevance never really died
welcome to the first undead game use any
item in your inventory and make
memes inside tuber simulator add some of
our patented stickers in there
stickers our emotions means our emotions
express your emotions with me
share them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows maybe i'll review your
memes the greatest honor of all time
full circle baby download it make a meme
[Music]
we need subtitles on this